digamos que tenemos tres pequeños
viveros este es el vivero y éste es el
vivero ve y acá tenemos al vivero cm y
vamos a suponer que este primer vivero
es un vivero privado tiene dueño le
pertenece a lin y acá este otro le
pertenece este vivero le pertenece a
racing ajá pero este vivero de en medio
es un vivero como un digamos que es un
vivero abierto al público así que lo voy
a escribir es un vivero abierto al
público entonces digamos que el inide y
si érase una vez érase una vez
lin y daisy eran pescadores decidiera
pescadora también link ambas les
encantaba ir de pesca y así es como se
ganaban la vida tiene una forma de vivir
no haciendo lo que te gusta y bueno
lynn tiene este vivero en el cual tiene
peces peces felices y ella va a pescar a
su vivero pero ella se asegura de no
sobre pescar porque bueno no quiere
agotar su estanque entonces ella pesca
lo suficiente como para sobrevivir se
puede decir pagar sus deudas vivir
contenta pero no tanto como para
extinguir extinguir todos los peces
daisy hace lo mismo ella también tiene
peces en su estanque y de eso vive lo
saca los vende se los come como sea pero
ella ella también tiene cuidado de no
sobre sobre pescar porque si sobre pesca
imagina no habrá otra generación de
peces pero aquí en este estanque en el
estanque abierto al público hay también
hay peces voy a dibujar los naranja así
y bueno quizás están sonriendo bueno no
por mucho por mucho tiempo porque ya
sabemos su destino pero
qué crees que pasará nuestra historia
cualquiera puede ir a pescar a ese
vivero público entonces este es un mundo
bueno de todas personas este es de
fantasía y real pero lynn dice lo
siguiente dice bueno yo soy cuidadoso
con mi estanque pero puedo ir en
cualquier momento a pescar a este a este
dinero público y puedo ahí pescar todo
lo que yo quiera y quizás ella esté
preocupada de que se agote el vivero si
agoten los peces en el vivero pero pero
si ella se preocupa ella piensa que si
se preocupan bueno también va haber
gente que no se preocupe de si puede ir
a pescar y tal vez haya no le no le
importe tanto el hecho de que se agote
el vivero y entonces si no se va a
beneficiar así que cuando tenemos este
dinero abierto al público toda la gente
ya sea link o daisy bueno también
supongamos que que hay más gente de
hecho de hecho conviene tener más
personajes en nuestra historia ellos
dirán mira yo voy a pescar aquí obtendré
algún beneficio y si sobre pesco mi
beneficio va a ser de sobre pescar
bueno yo obtendré todo todos esos peces
pero las consecuencias de sus actos
es que el costo de la sobrepesca en el
futuro no habrá peces no habrá pesa
alguno y eso afectará a todas las
personas y como no hay quien sea dueño
de esta tierra no hay quien no hay nadie
que la proteja llamémosle el guardián
del vivero este no existe no existe el
guardián del vivero tenemos que entonces
este vivero los personajes racionales y
racionales no siempre no siempre son
este buenos ellos van a sobre pescar y
esencialmente por hacer esto todos van a
vivir peor se va a destruir la
productividad de este vivero destruirán
la productividad del vivero del vivero y
esta idea que si hay una tierra común o
un recurso común que en este caso fue
fue un vivero y la gente puede
distribuir los costos y obtener
beneficios directamente entonces
esencialmente tenemos una situación
donde ese recurso compartido puede ser
abusado y eso a eso se le llama la
tragedia de los comunes la tragedia de
los comunes es un perfecto título para
esta historia atrás
de los comunes en este ejemplo hicimos
que el vivero fuera del espacio común
que está siendo abusado y ya más o menos
lo dije si el índice bueno sabes que yo
me voy a abstener de sobre pescar porque
yo no quiero que este recurso se agote
pero si yo hago eso otras personas van a
agotar lo iban a beneficiarse entonces
yo para que me abstengo y habrá otras
personas que piensen igual y esto se va
a agotar el ejemplo clásico de tragedia
de los comunes es la de los terrenos con
pasto común es la misma idea si si aquí
tenemos un terreno un terreno privado
con pasto donde tú puedes poner vacas
borregos lo que sea y acá tenemos otro
terreno con pasto y también es privado
pero si hay una en medio donde
cualquiera puede alimentar su ganado
entonces justo como en los viveros dirán
ellos van a dejar que su ganado se coma
y acaben con el pasto que más les da o
sea harán que la tierra sea no
sustentable pero el costo será que esa
tierra ya no va a servir y quien sé
quién se la gastó quien se gastó el
pasto obviamente ese beneficio
y bueno aquí yo tengo una una pregunta
bastante interesante
cuál es la solución a la tragedia de
comunes cuál es la solución a la traje
de comunes como le hace un gobierno o
una jurisdicción o un grupo de personas
para evitar este tipo de destrucción en
un recurso y bueno hay una manera de
hacerlo tú puedes puedes convertir esto
en una tierra privada se puede vender
acceso el gobierno podría vender acceso
a este lugar y si el gobierno retiene un
control sobre este lugar puedes vender
permisos para ingresar entonces puede
vender permisos y bueno si eres un
pescador responsable que vas a pescar en
un día dado y bueno puedes obtener tal
vez no sé quizás 200 pesos en valor por
hacer eso pero también te tendrá que
cobrar
y para el permiso supongamos que 50
pesos para mantener ese lugar pues bien
y claro claro que también se va a
limitar la cantidad de peces que hay ahí
entonces también se debe cuidar que no
muchos permisos se den y eso lo vemos
pasar muy seguido 6 seguido pasan si tú
quieres ir de cacería
necesitas un permiso si quiere decir de
pesca también en muchos lugares
necesitas un permiso si quieres incluso
ir un día de campamento también porque
bueno te podrías quedar a vivir ahí
quién sabe no se puede ensuciar todo
todo el espacio mucha gente se queda a
vivir ahí bueno todo el mundo al gusto
entonces la mejor manera de evadir esto
es por medio de permisos la mejor manera
de evadir la traje de los comunes es por
medio permisos y colorín colorado hasta
pronto